two things I've been noticing lately
babushkas old grannies looking like they
could use some cheering up
and then walls these physical walls but
also the walls between all of us so I
have an experiment bit nervous don't
really know where it's gonna go but I'm
going to try to break down these walls
and well you'll see
[Music]
I don't know I see Babu shkas every day
in the city
in this morning when we have the shoot
all I got was one angry Babs that hit
the flowers Bruce Lee once said now you
put water in a cup it becomes the cup
water can flow or it can crash be water
my friend geez and love Krishna the
other not creation
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful Bob we still on the bench I'm
going in
[Music]
Collison
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry
let's you guys
[Music]
that was definitely a rush and well bit
uncomfortable at times but guys super
cool today giving babushkas flowers on
the streets so I want to start holiday
June 24th International Babu shik a day
where we all all of us give flowers to
Bob Lucia's old grannies on the streets
and whatever city you're in
whatever street you're on whatever town
you're in around the world let's fire
these old ladies up seriously it was
like a pretty you for experience it's a
little bit uncomfortable I'm not gonna
lie it's a little bit uncomfortable but
the feeling you get afterwards is is
super rewarding okay do it
[Music]
you